[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn if you enjoy my content click
the like button
the youtube algorithm is strange and the
engagement helps tremendously
thanks guys once
mankind looked up at the night sky at
the stars shining in the black abyss
and they called them gods eventually we
realized that in actuality
our own sun was just like each of those
billions of stars out there in the
darkness
it only took one leap of thought for
someone to ask the question
if each of those stars are sons just
like ours
do they have planets just like ours as
well
and if they have planets then could
there be life
like us on other worlds
in my last video a brief history of
space travel in science fiction
we discussed lucian's second work true
history
which depicts lucian's journey through
outer space
where he encounters alien life forms we
also mentioned voltaire's
1752 story micromegas
which centers around a giant alien who
goes on a journey throughout the
universe
the fact that we have a work dating back
to the year 300 a.d
depicting aliens shows that the idea
that humans are not alone in the
universe
is just as ancient as the idea of
traveling through space
cosmic pluralism is the specific term
for what i'm describing here
it is the idea that there are many
inhabited worlds beyond ours
galileo didn't develop the heliocentric
model of our solar system
until the early 17th century
that means humans had been thinking
about life on other worlds even before
it became clear
that the earth revolved around the sun
in actuality humans have been discussing
the idea of general cosmic pluralism
since as early as the time of greek
philosopher anaximander
who lived from 610 bc to 546 bc
anaximander supposed that infinite
worlds appeared and disappeared
and cycles of birth and destruction
cosmic pluralism was adopted by
the atomist of that age who believed
that everything in the universe could be
broken down into divisible parts known
as atoms
it was reported that when an axis a
greek philosopher of the school of
democritus told alexander the great that
there were infinite worlds
he wept for he had yet to conquer even
one
the idea of the existence of alien life
in the direct sense
in contrast to general cosmic pluralism
actually became possible with the
introduction of the heliocentric model
of the solar system due to this
literature
involving extraterrestrial life became
popular in the 1600s and the 1700s
french author bernard le boviera de
fontanelli
i think i'm pronouncing that right
published conversations on the plurality
of worlds which went on to be thought of
as one of the first major works of the
age of enlightenment
the book discusses the heliocentric
model of the universe
as well as the possibility of alien life
on other worlds
it wasn't however until humankind
developed an understanding
of interstellar space in the late 19th
century and the early 20th century
that the idea of alien life on other
worlds really took off in fiction
though the first galaxies were actually
identified by astronomer charles messier
in the 18th century he did not know what
they were
in fact until about a hundred years ago
the milky way was believed to be only a
few thousand light years across
we didn't actually begin to comprehend
the actual size of the universe
until 1925. on january 1st of that year
edwin powell hubble announced that he
had discovered the existence of galaxies
countless giant clusters of stars out
there in space
our solar system was merely one of
endless solar systems within just one of
endless galaxies how many of those
galaxies had stars
that had planets how many of those
planets contained
life but even before this
humans had already begun to develop
ideas about what alien life forms would
be
like it would be strange to talk about
this subject
without mentioning one of the most
famous alien science fiction books of
all time
in 1898 h.g wells published what will
become one of the most famous
works in all of science fiction no one
would have believed
in the last year of the 19th century
that this world was being watched keenly
and closely by intelligences greater
than man's
and yet as mortal as his own that as men
busy themselves about their various
concerns
they were scrutinized and studied
perhaps almost as narrowly as a man with
a microscope might scrutinize
the transient creatures that swarm and
multiply in a drop of water
the war of the worlds tells the story of
a martian invasion of earth
from the perspective of a writer of
philosophy who lived in south
east england with his wife he is never
actually named
in the novel a series of explosions on
the surface of mars gains the attention
of the scientific community sometime
after this
a cylinder lands near the protagonist
home
within the cylinder were bare-sized
aliens
with oily grey skin and large darkly
colored eyes
those who have never seen a living
martian can scarcely imagine the strange
horror
of its appearance the peculiar v-shaped
mouth
with its pointed upper lip the absence
of brow
ridges the absence of a chin beneath the
wedge-like lower lip
the incessant quivering of this mouth
the gorgon groups of tentacles the
tumultuous breathing of
the lungs in a strange atmosphere the
evident
heaviness and painfulness of movement
due to the greater gravitational energy
of the earth
above all the extraordinary intensity
of the immense eyes were at once vital
intense and human crippled and monstrous
it is obvious to the narrator that the
alien life forms are not accustomed to
the environment of earth
as they have trouble breathing in
earth's atmosphere and have difficulty
adapting to the gravity of earth
the grotesque alien life forms begin
attacking the locals
their technology is far superior to any
technology found on earth
their tripod fighting machines had
powerful heat rays
and also shot out poisonous black gas
after laying assault on the planet earth
and seeming undefeatable
the aliens began dropping dead they had
not become accustomed to the microcosmos
of the earth
and ended up being defeated by common
earth pathogens
and scattered about it some in their
overturned war machines
some in the now rigid handling machines
a dozen of them stark and silent laid in
a row
where the martians dead slain by the
putrefactive and diseased bacteria
against which their systems were
unprepared
slain as the red weed was being slain
slain after all man's devices had failed
by the humless thing god in his wisdom
had put upon the earth
the war of the worlds was initially
published in a serialized form
in pearson's magazine in 1897
and then later reprinted in a 1927 issue
of the magazine amazing stories h.g
wells in this story appears to be using
the martian invasion of earth
to make commentary on the horrors of
real-world british colonization of
africa which had been going on for many
decades at the time of the book's
publication
already dozens of african territories
had been claimed by the british empire
by 1900
on the reverse side of this we have
robert hineland's
1959 book starship troopers
and starship troopers the human military
faces off against
insect-like alien life forms they called
them bugs
heinlein's view in starship troopers is
based on the idea
of claiming the frontier in essence the
book suggested that in order to survive
humankind would have to continue to push
the frontier violently
even at the expense of the indigenous in
this case
insect-like aliens it's been pointed out
that heinlein seems to be using the
aliens
as a metaphor for various indigenous
groups of earth
mainly the people of communist countries
essentially the story itself is based on
social darwinism
specifically the view of society as a
struggle for survival
based on militaristic force in direct
opposition to the work of isaac asimov
who famously states in his foundation
saga
violence is the last refuge of the
incompetent
heinlein insists that some conflicts can
only be resolved through violence
violence naked force has settled more
issues in history
than has any other factor
it almost seems as if heinlein is
deliberately contradicting asimov here
much of heinlein's viewpoint came from
his own belief
that the united states government at the
time was being too
easy on china and the soviet union
heinlein believed that violence was
often in fact
an effective method for settling
conflict
when you vote you are exercising
political authority
you're using force and force my friends
is violence
the supreme authority from which all
other authorities are derived
though the war of the worlds and
starship troopers
are making seemingly opposite statements
about colonialism
they both portray alien life in a
similar way
the aliens are otherized animal-like and
grotesque
they are inhuman something other than us
because they are portrayed as something
other than us
the reader isn't really inclined to view
aliens with any sort of
empathy they are the enemy the invaders
the others the animal-like
characteristics further help drive home
the point
still it is not uncommon for aliens and
fiction to have characteristics of
animals
but also sometimes the opposite was the
case
unlike the aliens that appear in the war
of the worlds and starship
troopers many early works depicted alien
beings as similar
or identical to humans edgar rice
burrows mars series
which was first serialized in 1912
depicted martians who looked almost
identical to human beings
but with variant skin tones and
sometimes extra limbs
in ursula k le guin's heinous psycho
books which begin being published in
1966
and continued throughout the 60s and 70s
the idea of an ancient race of beings
depositing similar dna throughout the
cosmos
is used to explain the humanoid life
forms that appear
throughout the series obviously parallel
evolution
of the same exact species was virtually
impossible
so the idea of a singular race seeding
genetically similar life throughout the
universe
made a lot of sense this is also similar
to the explanation given
in the star trek universe to explain the
similarities between the inhabitants of
the milky way
star trek began airing in 1966
but it wasn't explained why many alien
life forms and humans are similar
until the second series star trek the
next generation
humans vulcans klingons and many
others share similar characteristics
it is revealed in the 1993 episode of
star trek the next generation
the chase that all humanoid aliens had
originated from a single species
the klingons and the cardassians reject
this knowledge when it's given
insistent on racial superiority while
the romulan captain however
expresses to captain picard that perhaps
the two species are not as different as
they
seem even when aliens don't necessarily
look like humans
alien races and science fiction are
often used as a way for writers to make
analogs for various social
and political groups of people in their
own societies
for instance in star trek the next
generation
while the federation represents a
socialist utopia
the alien life forms known as the
ferengi who were originally intended to
replace the klingons as the main
adversary of the federation
represented the capitalist of old earth
capitalism no longer existed on earth
during this time
due to the fact that scarcity had been
eliminated through technology
the ferengi are repeatedly depicted as
morally bankrupt
and willing to do almost anything to
turn a profit
the depiction of capitalism in star trek
the next generation
is largely due to the creator gene
roddenberry's strong anti-capitalist
views
gene roddenberry considered himself a
humanist he rejected religion from a
young age
and was outspoken about his views mostly
and he made it clear that star trek was
his vision of the future
now let's take a closer look at the
humanoid aliens known
as the cardassians
the kardashians were meant to represent
fascists
they were a xenophobic race quick to
torture
captured enemies cardassian individuals
put service
of the state above all else even their
families
they valued strength above most things
and resented the weak
society operated based on a strict
hierarchy
and they were known for genetic
engineering which the federation
generally frowned upon
inserting certain characteristics and
viewpoints into alien species
was often a way in which writers were
able to make criticisms
about certain ideologies and belief
systems without overtly doing so
though one could argue that star trek
was never the most subtle
at doing this
i think one of the reasons humans keep
telling stories about
aliens is simply this we are afraid of
aliens
what happens if the aliens are not
friendly
like the vulcans from star trek what if
they are hostile
what if we cannot defend against them
what if an alien life form
conquers the earth and we are no longer
the dominant species on our own home
planet
arthur c clarke deals with the idea of
an alien invasion
in a very interesting way in his 1953
book
childhoods end it begins in the late
20th century
with huge alien spaceships suddenly
appearing above
earth's major cities they announced that
they will take control of the planet
in order to prevent the extinction of
humankind
humanity has no way of resisting mostly
the alien life-forms who become known as
the overlords
do not intervene in human affairs but
many remain suspicious
early on in the book secretary general
of the u.n manages to see the true
form of the alien overlords who have
promised to reveal themselves in 50
years
after humankind had become accustomed to
their presence on earth
what he sees terrifies him to the point
where he never speaks of what he saw
the overlords do indeed foster a new era
of prosperity a golden age for humanity
but at the expense of human creativity
some argued that the overlords had
intentionally stifled human ingenuity
causing society to become stagnant the
overlords
as they said they would revealed
themselves 50 years after their initial
arrival on planet earth
they had the appearance of demons they
are horned
with cloven hooves wings and barbed
tails
it was a tribute to the overlord's
psychology
and to their careful years of
preparation that only a few people
fainted
yet there could have been fewer still
anywhere in the world
who did not feel the ancient terror
brush for one awful instant
against their mind before reason
banished it forever
there was no mistake the leathery wings
the horns the barbed tail all were there
the most terrible of all legends had
come to life
out of the unknown past yet now it stood
smiling
in ebon majesty with the sunlight
gleaming upon its tremendous body
and with a human child resting
trustfully on either
arm eventually one character
jan rodricks managed to sneak aboard and
stow away
on one of the overlord supply ships and
ends up journeying more than
40 light years to their home planet
though
only a few weeks passed for him more
than 80 years pass on earth
more than a hundred years after the
overlords arrived on the planet
human children started to demonstrate
extraordinary mental
abilities including telekinesis and
clairvoyance
the overlords eventually reveal their
true purpose on earth
they serve what they call the overmind
and they had been sent to the planet by
this cosmic intelligence
to aid in the evolution of the human
species
we believe it is only a theory
that the overmind is trying to grow to
extend its powers
and its awareness of the universe by now
it must be the sum of many races
and long ago it left the tyranny of
matter behind
it is conscious of intelligence
everywhere
when it knew that you were almost ready
it sent us here
to do its bidding to prepare you for the
transformation
that is now at hand the human race as
they knew it
was coming to an end the next stage of
humanity would no longer
consist of individual minds the children
being born would share one mind
and eventually join the overmind which
was made up by many ancient
civilizations who had shed their
material existence
it is explained that the overlords
cannot join with the overmind
the character george gregson refers to
them as trapped
in an evolutionary cul-de-sac unable to
advance any further
here was a great and noble race in
almost every way superior to mankind
yet it had no future and it was aware of
it
the overlord served as a bridge species
which fostered a race until it could
eventually join with the overmind
eventually children stop being born on
earth
and the hundreds of millions of them
present are taken to a separate
continent
the old human race dies off as the new
human race's final transformation begins
only jan rodricks is left to witness the
final transformation of the children
and the death of the earth he is the
last remaining homo sapien
the earth's atoms are consumed as the
children shed their physical forms
transforming into a giant column of
light which dissolves into space
jan is there as the human species ends
forever
in a glorious flash of light there goes
the river
no change in the sky though i can hardly
breathe
strange to see the moon still shining up
there i'm glad they left it
but it will be lonely now the light
from beneath me inside the earth shining
upward
through the rocks the ground everything
growing brighter
brighter blinding childhoods end is not
a typical example of what people think
of
when they hear alien takeover or alien
invasion
there are no giant weapons or science
fiction battles
the book is philosophical and
existential
but also hopeful in some way the
overlords are the shepherds of the
ending of humanity
but it's only the ending of humanity as
we once were
it is an evolution of the species into
something higher
just as we evolved from apes
of course there are countless stories
depicting alien life forms at this point
in time
i've had to be highly selective about
the stories i chose to highlight in this
video
otherwise this video will be way too
long
the idea of extraterrestrial life is an
idea that humans can't seem to let go of
are we alone in the universe what would
happen
if we ever made contact with an alien
race
would they be friendly would they share
their technology and culture with us
or would they be hostile intent on
dominating or exterminating us and
harvesting the
resources of our planet for themselves
the idea of other intelligent life out
there is intriguing
and terrifying and wondrous all at the
same time
and there is also something strangely
sad about the thought
that out of all the worlds out there
that ours would be the only one with
life
nowadays it's more common than ever for
people to believe that
alien life exists out there somewhere
as merely a matter of probability the
famous drake equation was meant to
calculate the amount of inhabited worlds
that existed in the universe and
according to it
the universe should be full of life even
still
in reality it is unlikely that we will
ever encounter life
that has evolved outside of our planet
the universe is simply too big and the
distances between the stars simply too
great
even at the speed of light it would take
countless human generations to reach
other solar systems
let alone other galaxies so all we
really have
is our stories in science fiction we can
explore the what ifs
of extraterrestrial existence what if we
could reach them
what if they could reach us
what if they are just like us what if
they are
nothing like us is alien life
even something that we will be able to
recognize as life in the first place
everything that evolved on earth is in
some ways similar
carbon-based sharing genetics
what would something of an entirely
different evolutionary tree even look
like
these are all questions that science
fiction authors have attempted to answer
in their stories
throughout the decades and who knows
maybe one day we will make contact
hopefully we'll be mature enough as a
species to deal with such a thing
now i for one have always loved the
concept of alien life forms
i love reading books about aliens a
weird one that i really love
is stephen king's dream catcher such an
odd and strange book
not the best ending but still pretty
cool and hey it's stephen king
let me know what you guys favorite alien
books are
i'm always looking for recommendations
heck i'll even take movies or tv shows
thanks so much for watching guys make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
[Music]
you